I know you wouldn't approve what I did I
mean I know it's not what you would have
wanted but you were always better than
me Laurel I hate you promise me
something anything your instinct is
always to go
you have been waiting for things to go
back to the way things were there not
Felicity thinks that it's time we put
together a new team
Evelyn sharp I had this so wrong this
his name is Rene Ramirez yeah but well
dog is much scarier I thought you didn't
want to be a vigilante I never want to
feel helpless again these people are
amateurs Felicity inspired by you I came
here to work with the guy who killed
damian darhk-- first I'm gonna teach you
a few things I'll play
first part of initiation only birthing
you didn't trust yourself or you told me
that dead don't want anything either I'm
willing to do whatever is necessary or I
shouldn't be up there at all which is
exactly why I can't be
Green Arrow
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow season 5 trailer video
we're just affectionately calls season 5
van Dijk rising so here we go so the big
idea this trailer is setting up new team
arrow so you have the wild dog character
Artemis you probably remember from last
season she's going to become the Artemis
of the DC canon most of you probably
know the character from Young Justice
there was also a comic book version of
the character that was a little
different but most people just remember
the Young Justice version but then you
have mr. terrific also stepping up to
try to become an actual vigilante so the
first couple of episodes especially like
the first two episodes are gonna be like
Oliver's version of Full Metal Jacket
only he's going to be the drill sergeant
there's another vigilante who's the new
district attorney he becomes a vigilante
later in the season he is a very
Punisher type backstory where like he's
this upstanding member of the community
he's the district attorney but his
family gets murdered because as all
these vigilantes have decided Star City
has gone to [ __ ] and the criminals have
taken over so they want to clean it up
taking their cues from Green Arrow just
inspired by him but some of them like
wild dog for instance take it way too
far so what it seems like they're
teasing is is that some of the
vigilantes that pop up Oliver is going
to take under his wing like the new
recruits here and some he's going to
have to take down this looks like it's
Ragman probably one of the vigilantes
who's trying to do a good thing but
going way over the line in the comics he
actually draws power from the souls that
are kind of sewn into his jacket but he
is a good character who seems like he's
gonna be batshit crazy on the TV show
the big villain that like the big bat
they finally announced like we see Chad
Coleman's character here he's an
antagonist but I actually found out that
he's not going to be the official big
bat he'll just be a recurring villain in
the tone of stringer Bell like he'll be
consolidating a lot of the gang power in
Star City the official Big Bad and this
is actually a big name from the comics
that'll like make a little light bulb go
on over your head prometheus is the big
bad most of you remember him from the
cry for justice arc as the person who
chopped off
Roy's arm so Colton Haynes better steer
clear this season if he wants to keep
both of his arms intact but that's a
good question a lot of you are probably
asking is Roy going to come back if
laurels gonna come back and flashbacks
then you know why wouldn't Roy come back
in present-day well they haven't
confirmed anything but I you know I
totally think that it's possible
the Colton Haynes could come on for an
episode but really like the biggest new
additions to the show this season our
Artemis they haven't said how many
episodes she's gonna be a part of wild
dog the district attorney and then
obviously like the big villain
Prometheus so for those of you that have
read comics you've seen the versions of
Prometheus neither one really looks like
this
so arrow is doing a version of the
backstory that's relatively true to the
character he'll just look a little bit
different there are actually three
versions of Prometheus from the comics
one was an imposter the first one
actually worked for the original dr.
alchemy so this is like way way back in
the comics there's a Blue Beetle
crossover where he's trying to steal
from Ted Kord sounds very like arrow
arrow makes very good use of court
industries even though it is thus far
been unable to do Ted Kord himself so
really like the arrow version of the
character is closer to the second
version that's the cry for justice like
Roy arm ripping off version of
Prometheus so his TV backstory for
season 5 is gonna play a lot like his
comic book origin story he's the son of
two criminals who were then later gunned
down he grows up and seeks revenge on
the police that killed his parents even
though his parents were dirtbags he
still wants revenge on them he doesn't
really become a Justice League villain
until he finds this like
multi-dimensional space that he sets up
a basin he gets this advanced helmet
that's when things really go off the
rails and he goes after the Justice
League the way they're doing it on the
arrow TV shows they're saying that
Oliver is responsible for Prometheus
becoming prometheus
they're saying it goes back to season
one so what it sounds like is going on
that in season 1 when Oliver was
dropping bodies left and right his
parents were on the list
Oliver killed them because they failed
to city you know whatever they were
doing was really bad but then later
Oliver has this epiphany hey I shouldn't
be killing people anymore I'm gonna try
and find a better way to do this he
becomes the green arrow eventually as of
last season but this whole time
prometheus doesn't give a [ __ ] about any
of that he's been training to avenge his
parents no matter how bad they were so
in the way that a lot of the bad things
that are going to be happening on the
flash are Barry's fault because of
flashpoint stuff a lot of the bad stuff
that's going to be happening that
Prometheus is doing on arrow will be
Oliver's fault so just based on the
pitch based on the trailer it seems like
everything's going to be pretty tight
this season they're not
doing any crazy magic stuff it's gonna
be a lot closer to the season 1 to
season 2 arc where they developed the
Deathstroke character that he later
became this very personal but very
dangerous villain so some of you were
asking me about the difference in the
suit like year they were like hey Oliver
doesn't wear a face covering that's
Prometheus so you can see that the
person mistakes him for the green arrow
but he kills him
so Prometheus seems like he's going to
be dragging the green arrows name
through the mud a little but it sounds
like the news reporters like the other
people of the city might not be able to
make that distinction like they just see
a green hooded costume so they assume
he's the green arrow so that's the tease
we'll see where they go with it from
there but let me know in the comments
what do you guys think about them doing
the Artemis character and what do you
think about them doing prometheus like I
feel like he's gonna do something really
terrible to at least one of the team
arrow members I don't know if anybody's
gonna get their arm ripped off like they
didn't cry for justice and Oliver ended
up killing him at the end of that arc
which he kind of did a damien darhk's so
they've kind of already done the payoff
from cry for justice
Prometheus gravely wounds Roy almost
destroys the city so Oliver kills him
damian darhk-- did that last season
Oliver ended up killing like he killed
Laurel so then Oliver later killed him
because it was going to kill all these
other people so we'll see what the
payoff ends up being but I'm just
expecting to see some Easter eggs from
cry for justice so hopefully Roy shows
up hopefully he gets his arm chopped off
but if that sounds a little morbid and
you guys didn't see my legends of
tomorrow video remember this is a
four-night crossover and katie cassidy
just signed a contract to be a series
regular on all four shows now they have
only explained how that's gonna work
because i think on arrow she's only
going to appear in flashbacks but on the
other shows that's kind of up of grabs
like she'll probably be black siren when
she shows up on the flash who knows
legends of tomorrow if she appears on
Supergirl she'll probably do birds of
prey stuff so the other big thing the
flashbacks clearly he's going to Russia
they're gonna do the Bratva arc Anatole
is back which is fun he was a fun
character in season 2 we haven't seen
him in a while so they haven't really
announced any special characters like
any comic book characters they're gonna
show up in that flashback arc so for
those of you asking hey is cagey beast
couldn't show up in the flashback arcs
well the funny thing like if you didn't
know the Anatoly character is actually
cagey beast in the comics so this is
arrows version of KGB's so I don't know
if
gonna be doing any comic-book arcs in
the flashbacks how they're gonna link to
the future it's open to speculation but
the other big thing is Cody Rhodes like
he keeps hyping up his guys to parents
like he's gonna be beating the [ __ ] out
of Stephen Amell which I totally love
it's gonna be a lot of fun I think he's
only gonna be in a one-off episode you
know maybe he'll appear in multiple
episodes it depends on whether or not
they kill him at the end and I think you
know because they like him they'll
probably let him crawl away with his
life so that he could always come back
in the future but I don't know if he's
gonna play a comic-book character
they're keeping the character he's
playing secrets so I think it is a comic
book character hopefully he gets to play
sports master because on Young Justice
that was Artemis's father even though on
arrow the character that is becoming
Artemus had parents that were killed by
damian darhk-- so the backstory is a
little bit different but it'd just be
really cool to see him play sports
master it you know be character that's
not super big and someone that could
just recur every once in a while but
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's DC giveaway winner Josh Davidson
you win a $20 Amazon gift card just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there's a bunch more DC
videos I'll be doing this week for
Justice League for like the movie stuff
and for the TV shows so be sure to
subscribe to get everything it'll be a
new round of the giveaway - there's
still a whole bunch of stuff left over
from Comic Con that we have to talk
about so my next video will probably be
a flash video where you guys wait for
that video to post you can click here
for my breakdown to the flash season 3
trailer and you can click here to learn
all about iron spider and Spider Man
homecoming thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight